on veut aussi sûreté moment à toi parce
qu'on a montré will smith il ya un
instant il ya bien d'autres pour mon
qu'on voulait revoir c'est en radio
cette fois tu recevais djamel sur nrj et
sans le vouloir
tu as fait un festival de boulet alors
ça c'est le moment le plus jeune je peux
expliquer à sur wii jeu j'ai expliqué
avant c'est le moment le plus gênant
parce que quand je reçois des invités je
veux que tout le monde soit traité de la
même façon les petits artistes les
grands les grandes stars internationales
et jamel dans ma tête je me suis dit
surtout à aucun moment on fait pas de
gaffe
voilà sur ou le handicap ou la main etc
je m'étais mis en tête je me suis dit
surtout voilà on fait un truc le plus
mais tu sais quand tu te dis surtout
fait attention là tu les enchères c'est
quand tu dis fais attention à tout ça il
prend des 31 décembre le champagne pour
tout le monde dans la salle ça va tout
vous ai dit tu joues sur le maroc on
joue sur le maroc jamais je l'avais à ma
droite turque a cependant tout est
endommagée trompe malicki mais j'ai fait
comme je lui ai dit aux élèves de la
main droite et dit je le jure mais
comment j'ai fait
et après tu le dis ça c'est entre tes
mains
c'est à tout puissant je suis jamais
autant excuser de ma vie mais
virtuellement djamel si tu regardes
celui-ci l'a bien compris et accepté
mais voilà la belle gamelle on le fait
mais ça fait partie des trucs où tu te
conditionne à l'avancé et tu vois là ego
et ben ouais alors il ya un autre truc
je voulais revoir parce que tu étais
quand même je le redis à chaque fois tu
t'es le seul à m'inviter dans la méthode
khoury mais à chaque fois je vous disais
je disais des équipes mais je n'ai rien
à vendre je n'ai pas de promo en serbie
mais c'était un plaisir question de
plaisir on est dans le dôme est donc un
moment et à l'époque je fasse quelque
chose parce que je l'avais pas de promo
un moment il fallait que j'aille le
fauteuil on avait bon c'était tout dit
quoi en ces mots je m'étais pris d'amour
pour quelqu'un dans le public
souviens toi je me suis pris un énorme
vent par patoche qui étaient dans le
public c'est une grande histoire d'amour
qui avait commencé mais qui a été vite
avortés ça a été de sept personnes a été
choisi au hasard au hasard ne savais pas
du tout regarde
[Rires]
mais il est un peu fou il est fougueux
mais la syrie lève la vie et tous et
vous l'amour matin là c'est le stim
taillé pour lui
oui patrick tu sais écouter monsieur
courir je vais prendre le plateau en
otage si patrick de japan embrasser dans
les 15 secondes
cette émission était non le fait balcon
je demande patrick avec un hélico et une
renault mais regarde l'émission toutes
les brigades qui a baissé de toi et on
ne craint plus rien sébastien c'est le
mali
g
[Musique]
depuis longtemps déjà que monsieur vous
écoutez tout de suite oui allez voir
moisir oui j'aimerais dire que je suis
amoureux d'une personne ressent dans son
public une personne pourvu d'une
moustache bicéphale
patrick je peine à l'audio et je suis
maudit
[Musique]
vouloir sans le vouloir c'était le
prémice de ton look ya quelque chose il
ya quelque chose que j ai joué ailleurs
patrick rolland brassens il y voit là si
nous regarde
c'est toujours cela est encore là et on
envoie stobart aussi qu'on a dû se
marrer tous merci
voilà qui était votre jean lassalle est
le jean là et toi toi j'étais ton pote
tu me dis rien je me laisse venir comme
ça parce que moi même jamais des jeans
très particulier aussi à l'heure